[Music]
hey we're back again
it's monday yeah no i thought it was
tuesday all day today for some reason i
don't [ __ ] know why even though i put
the garbage out this morning and
everything you
think i know it was monday but no um
dj maniac so here's something that you
pointed out that i
didn't even realize you said dj manic
says i'm only here for a second my
friend henry
from last podcast on the left is in this
movie and i didn't even re i didn't even
realize when i was watching the movie
because i thought the dude's voice
sounded kind of familiar and then like i
was reading a review of it and they were
talking about him like
he was famous like the dude that played
the cop and i was like oh it's henry
zabrowski
from last podcast on the left i can't
believe i didn't make that connection
you've been on that show huh
no you haven't okay no i listen to that
show a lot because they're
sound familiar they're funny as hell
they do well they do a lot of true crime
[ __ ] so a lot of times i'll listen to
their uh treatment of something like
that yeah i heard it i've heard the name
of that podcast it was
i thought that was one of the ones that
maybe we did or something no
i know we've done so many things yeah i
mean last podcast
last podcast on the left probably
probably one of the most popular
uh true crime kind of uh podcasts out
there
i would imagine um but yeah it's three
guys that's they're [ __ ] hilarious
so yeah this movie here unless you
wanted to start out with something else
um now seth is in here got ces addicted
to blowfly
yeah they've been messaging yeah
they're not all great but you know uh
he's got a lot of good ones i liked his
version of blue monday too
and his version of [ __ ] when doves
cry of course the call
when does come yeah of course which is
more about pigeons [ __ ] on you than
anything else but it's [ __ ] funny
because of course the dude's just
[ __ ] out dude's just out of control
being in love with [ __ ] transsexuals
and all kinds of [ __ ] funny
funny [ __ ] transsexuals that flipped him
gay and just
crazy [ __ ] ones that he paid to blow him
while he was
in the park just crazy [ __ ] i mean
seriously
i feel like if blowfly was still alive
he sadly left us
yeah uh him and chuck tingle should have
done
a collaboration of some sort exactly the
same kind of have some multimedia
same kind of thing i kind of feel like i
would have
paid a substantial amount of money to
see that yeah
because blowfly's got one one setting
and that's
super [ __ ] he could only talk about sex
and the
more filthy the better that's just
that's just what he does
well you know he found a niche and he
just like stuck with it he had that was
his brand he was very his
own brand yeah which you know yep you
guys
had some focus yeah kind of like
dolomite he was kind of trying
topping dolomite singing and [ __ ]
doing rap and entertaining it was
multimedia entertainment you know
pre-internet stuff you know skirting
censorship
he was shocked jocking yeah jack jack
yeah
much and telling stories storytelling
and singing
he could sing he didn't want to he could
say yeah what do you want to do yeah
he was rapping and singing you know what
i mean like i can sing when i want to
it's just most time i don't want to when
he got old he was just
just in this damn silly ass superhero
costume yeah
with his underwear on the outside of it
like with his long [ __ ] middle
fingers with the big old [ __ ]
he had pimp he had pin he had a pimp
hands you know he had a pen pants with a
big
long nails and [ __ ] he pointed his
middle finger at you and
just and he didn't really sing he's just
rapping you know rapping and the whole
[ __ ] crowd going wild
and the crowd goes too bad we didn't too
bad we didn't see him before he died i
know i kind of regret that actually
because i just i remember seeing that
poster he's the ultimate florida man the
ultimate
splash expression of [ __ ] floor
together i mean dude if he had eaten
another dude's face off
yeah he would have been the
quintessential i mean he may have at
some point we don't know
they just didn't find out about it he's
looking funny allegedly
yeah but um all right so this movie
we're talking about today
little flick called after midnight now
this actually they have it uh it
just recently uh showed up on shutter
and they have it listed as a 2021 movie
i guess because it didn't really get a
wide release until now when shutter
picked it up
although it was actually made and
premiered at the i think at the tribeca
film festival back in
uh 2019 in the spring it's just it was
called something else
that's what it was called it was called
something else that was the name of the
movie yeah
um you know in case that wasn't clear so
um
i don't want to spoil it too much i will
say
i i liked this movie a lot um it's
not really a horror movie so don't go
into it expecting a horror movie
it is essentially a romance or a
relationship
drama comedy that sometimes has a
monster in it
yeah do you think that's a good
description that's it yeah actually you
know i gotta say
the movie was a real good-looking movie
it was well shot had really good
soundscapes i like i liked the uh
uh it didn't it had a soundtrack but it
also had a soundscape behind it
yeah pretty cool um stylistically it was
really good
uh it had a monster in there and the
special effects for the monster was
pretty good yeah the monster is pretty
cool so
it's only a few seconds um it was a good
movie
uh especially i could tell that it was a
low budget movie
sure you know but it was a good real
good low budget movie i would left me
wanting a little more
i wanted more monster yeah but it's
probably expensive to make a lot of that
monster
well like as that's why i'm saying you
know it's a good movie you just have to
manage your expectations about what kind
of movie it is i wouldn't call it a
monster movie
no i would call it a relationship drama
with some comedy in it and also there's
a monster
a couple of times yeah that's fair you
know what i mean it wanted to be a
monster movie though so bad
in my soul you want everything
in a monster movie a little bit more of
a monster movie but i understand why
they did what they did
yeah it was a good looking movie it kind
of reminded me a little bit
um i was going to say in the sense that
like i said it's hard to talk about i
don't want to spoil it too much but it's
kind of one of those things
i can't remember what was that movie i
think it was just called monster that
was about a
mom and her daughter and they were
stranded out in this uh car
like at night and there was like a
monster stalking them it kind of gave me
that sort of vibe
where it was more it wasn't really about
the monster as much i think that was
like a werewolf or something
and it was kind of out there but it was
more like metaphorical like the monster
was real but it was kind of like
standing in for something yeah and i
think that's what
this movie is kind of doing that too a
little bit like the babadook but not
quite
as fantastical as that this is much more
grounded in reality even though there is
a monster in it it had a real good color
palette
and just the the the texture of the
movie visually i liked it
had a good cast acting was good uh
leading lady was uh she was cute she was
good at it
that was bria grant you know where
because the whole time in the movie i'm
like god damn it i know i've seen her in
some [ __ ] she was on dexter
okay uh she's been in a bunch of other
movies too like a lot of indie movies
and
you know she's done some tv but i think
that's probably where i recognized her
from
she had cute ears she had cute ears
i didn't i didn't notice her it was
showing her with her head back from
certain angles and just a little mouse
ears
she's like oh look at her little bitty
mouth she's like a little pixie
yeah she does she does definitely does
that have that look but so
the interesting thing about this is that
the dude that plays hank
jeremy gardner uh also directed it okay
so there you go
all right um so let's so the setup is
hank is uh this kind of
you know nice guy good old boy type of
thing they live out in
this town it's i think it's called
barlow they don't say what state it is i
think some of them say georgia but
when she goes to uh she goes somewhere
she goes to miami and she says it's only
three or four hours away so i was
assuming it was somewhere like in
central florida you know what i mean
like in
in the rural area of central florida
that's kind of what it looked like to me
so um but i don't know if they say what
state it's supposed to be in so it's
florida or georgia one of those two
places
so it's a town called barlow real real
small town uh you know all the dudes you
know go out and hunt or whatever
now uh so hank and his girlfriend
um abby have been together for 10 years
and they uh they own or manage a bar and
they live in this big huge
rambling old house that has been in
hank's family for
generations so very very early in the
film they do kind of like a lot of
flashbacks i think it's
i don't know if it's supposed to be set
in the 90s because it's very very 90s
like the dresses that she wears
very 90s there's a lot of 90s music in
it
there's a part where uh hank
pretty much karaoke's the entirety of
lisa loeb's
stay uh which is a highlight also
so i don't know if it was supposed to be
set in the 90s but it seems like it
seemed like 90s to me for the with the
music yeah and they had cassette tapes
you know what i mean so it felt like
1994 thereabouts but i didn't
meet the little sundress things that
they had back then
90s with little flower prints and [ __ ]
that was 90s i think
yeah that's what i'm saying it reminds
me it's like very 1990 is that a
sundress what kind of dress you call it
yeah it's kind of like this
yeah it's a sundress sort of um and it
had like sunflower patterns on it
it's like if you see the dresses in
there you'll be like it'll scream 90s
it's
90s which they need to bring them back
actually those were cute dresses
yeah on some people yeah well you had to
have the right
they look good on young girls yeah or
you know
you know 20s 20s and teenagers yeah it
looks good
um your stalker says the 80s rocked the
90s sucked to a large extent i would
agree with that assessment um i wasn't a
big fan of the 90s
but there were certain aspects of the
90s that were cool there were
yeah but the mainstream kind of sucked
yeah overall i'm pretty sure i like the
80s better
uh so yeah so they live in this place
now pretty early on
you know so there's like a lot of kind
of dreamy flashbacks of him
uh you know in their like different
stages of their relationship
and then they also intercut with him
with his couch pushed against the door
with a shotgun
and there's something kind of scrabbling
around on the outside on the porch yeah
now pretty early on in the movie abby
disappears well she doesn't disappear
but she leaves
and she doesn't really like she just
leaves a note that says something like
hey i'm going like whatever i love you
and then she won't answer her phone and
all this other kind of [ __ ] now i didn't
really realize until later on in the
movie that she was gone for a long time
because i was just kind of like how long
was she gone i guess it was like a month
yeah um so in the time that she's gone
and he can't get hold of her he doesn't
know
yeah i guess because nobody had cell
phones everybody still had land lines so
i'm guessing it was the 90s
so he can't get older he doesn't really
know where she went
and um you know he thinks that she's
just left him and is just like hey you
[ __ ] off or whatever
so he just kind of starts spiraling down
hill
and it seems that a monster
is coming and trying to get into his
house every night and he's been shooting
at it
um it takes their cat sadly
um and but everybody else in town like
his buddies and the cop who
as i said is played by henry zabrowski
from uh last podcast on the left
uh who is also abby's brother
that nobody believes him because you
wouldn't you would just think
dude's living out there by himself his
girlfriend left him and now he thinks
there's a monster coming in to get him
it's just a bear it's all this other
kind of [ __ ] so
that's kind of the setup of it so
um but as i said it's not
a horror movie it has horror movie
aspects to it there is a monster in it
but a lot of it is relationship stuff
some of it is funny like especially the
the interactions between him and his
buddy
like where the buddy is talking about
like all the discovery channel
[ __ ] like about the cryptids and you
know him drinking out of the off of the
bar mat and [ __ ] like that like that
[ __ ]
is funny so there's funny [ __ ] in it but
there's also real serious relationship
[ __ ]
like about his commitment issues and
about all this other kind of stuff so
there's that kind of so if that doesn't
sound like something you want to watch
then you shouldn't
um because it's not scary or anything
but overall i don't know i dug it i
thought that was all right that was
pretty good yeah
it's a pretty good movie just as long as
you're not expecting it to be
you know scary or no no no no
and i mean there is one scene in the
middle of it where
um you know where hank and abby are
having this like long
conversation about their relationship
and it's long i think it's like 13 or 14
minutes
and the movie's not long it's only like
83 minutes maybe i think it was 83
minutes
um so but but it's really good it's
really
well acted um you know and it's really
kind of
uh you know you kind of get
sort of emotionally invested with these
two characters or at least i did
um so you know it's it's a really good
movie just not
really a horror movie just my sister
looked great the monster
really looked good the monster looked
really good not in it much but he was
like
fantastic yeah and the the thing with
the cat i don't want a [ __ ] room
why did cats always get hurt these
movies
i was just i just liked the tone of the
movie you know it was just the way it
was shot
the shot composition was really good
they used good filters that seemed like
felt remember they could
the backgrounds were kind of soft
everything's things were color
coordinated with the [ __ ] blue yeah
gold and just things were so it had like
a little bit of a dreamy
especially after it got dark because
they were contrasting like his memories
yeah it's not like they're just shooting
it with a damn cell phone i mean it's
like a film
yeah it's like a film and i like to like
i said i can't spoil too much about it
but
all of the stuff that they show about
their relationship
early on like all of the flashbacks that
you have and stuff like after some [ __ ]
happens in the middle of the movie and a
conversation that they have in the
middle of the movie
um a lot of that stuff will become clear
like why that's in there
t's here haven't seen you in a while t
where you been she's saying she's gonna
watch this movie tonight
and she also recommends raw head rex you
talk about the original raw head rex the
irish one
we loved it when it came out when we
were kids but everybody [ __ ] bags on
that movie now
well it's terrible but it's terrible in
a super fun way when we were watching
that [ __ ] and it was like we were
watching some
underground this is back in the 80s
we ran it you know this we're watching
the [ __ ] lovecraft type movies you
know [ __ ] herbert west type movies
we put that [ __ ] in there and it was it
was irish it was calling us back to the
[ __ ] motherland
like what the [ __ ] is this going on when
we see that [ __ ]
rawhead rex piss on that priest to
baptize him he's going yeah
and we were just going yeah this movie's
[ __ ] right on first time i said it's
like yes that's a weird [ __ ] that's some
clyde barker sure right yeah
and then they had the downward right
they had the damn stained glass
window and there's like the monster
underneath the ground and there was
something with a key where it made
remember that where it shot some kind of
beam of light yeah i don't remember
exactly how
it's been a while since i've seen it but
we talked about a couple of years we
thought that was cool as [ __ ] at the
time i saw it
more recently and i was like oh that's
all that was you know but
it's funny how your perceptions change
as you get older and as things kind of
age out i mean
it last time i saw it look it was a
tired looking movie
but it it was cool in the day
you know what i think that it actually
would have been i think people fondly
remember it just because the
monster is so so goofy looking yeah
had the monster been scary
like the monster in the movie we're
talking about today had the monster
looked like that
then i think people would be talking a
lot more favorably about rawhead wrecks
because i did
actually like the [ __ ] around the
monster but as soon as the monster turns
up
yeah you're just like oh no they got him
out from underneath the damn stone
[ __ ]
[Music]
stone like a stonehenge stone he was
underneath that's how i remembered it he
was buried underneath
yeah weren't they digging around
somewhere and there was some kind of
obelisk or some [ __ ] and they moved it
don't move the envelope and it's like
that's this thing had this googly-eyed
monster came out yeah was he kind of
googly
did he have a mullet oh he had a mohawk
looked like a he looked kind of like a
cross between
a a pinhead or like you know what i mean
like a [ __ ]
like an encephaloid baby with a mohawk
and a demon and a gorilla and a pig all
kind of mixed in together and he had
tusks and [ __ ]
and kind of the bottom of his teeth we
liked it
i like it too it was a bug eye the only
thing that was wrong with it is that its
eyes didn't blink
but they didn't show it for very long
yeah they tried not to show it very
it reminded me that i just didn't blink
the eyes of it they were
narrow and they didn't blink like i said
this might be because it's been a while
since i've seen it
but the eyes of it reminded me a little
bit of the eyes from those
uh from like the [ __ ] what was that
movie horror
party beach with those monsters with
those big huge bug eyes and then they
look like their mouths were full of like
dill pickles or hot dogs or something
um i just i felt like the eyes reminded
me of that but i could be thinking of
something else
uh you know so to be here raw head rex
um it might suck by today's standards
but when we it was direct to video it's
still pretty fun
and we and it was not for a theater
audience it was for
young guys in high school listening to
heavy metal [ __ ] records
all right 16 17 year old guys and you've
rented that [ __ ] from [ __ ]
blockbuster along with two or three
other ones
and you watched them for the weekend
usually sneaking
sneaking booze or [ __ ] smoking weed
in between yeah of course
and uh you're just that helps impress
you you know about what it is
it's like you're kind of high you're
kind of buzzed yeah and then afterwards
you might
you and your boys would discuss it for a
couple of hours
about the lore behind it no you know was
there anything to and then you
would kind of convince yourself that it
was based on something that was real
you wanted to base it in some real [ __ ]
like we were trying to base
lovecraft stuff in real [ __ ] like oh
yeah i feel like a lot of people were
back then
well yeah what was funny about lovecraft
is that people during the time of
lovecraft were believing what he was
saying
that there really were cults and he
really did have this
remember that yeah he had a whole cult
following that thought that he was
really in contact with the with yes
with the paranormal he wasn't though but
that helped his [ __ ]
well and it helped too that other
authors that knew him
dipped into his right uh you know the
the whole world he had created and wrote
their own stories in it like
you know it's extended fiction you
weren't dealing with a jaded
audience back then no no internet so
there wasn't a lot of competition
they'd fell into that little scene or
reading them books and it
and it would change their lives because
that was the only influence they had
why'd you give it on facebook your
shit's dinging yeah somebody asked uh
if we were looking forward to antlers i
was actually i think that to me was the
biggest disappointment of
it being pushed back uh because i kept
seeing the trailers
for it last year when we were going to
the theater and i was just like man that
looks so good i just like i can't wait
to see that and then they just keep
pushing it back and pushing it back
i don't know why they don't like just
release it to vod like they did
everything else because i [ __ ] want
to see that [ __ ] and probably a lot of
people wanted to see it
i mean you know they would have made
money well that was the one about the
wendigo or whatever yeah the trailer
looked really good
so i don't know i'll watch it as soon as
it uh comes out
yeah raw head rex and humanoids from the
deep would be a good
double humanoids from the deep is a good
one too that had [ __ ] uh that
[ __ ] what's his [ __ ] uh dude man
what's that name doug mcclure
yeah when you got a [ __ ] creature
from the black black lagoon [ __ ]
jumping up trying to rape women and [ __ ]
you got to see that when you're a
teenager
yeah yeah trying to pull the women and
spawning with the women
yeah man spawn within that win you
better run
just [ __ ] you know that was the
mentality of the time and that really
should be the
mentality for all times the fit
that fish people should jump up on land
and start to and try to spawn with
human women yeah and bikinis in bikinis
and [ __ ] it's an effect that's the way a
world should work godzilla yeah
it's an effect it's an effective tool
it's an effective tool
to capture the minds of a teenage boy
yeah that's right and then what's
produced afterwards
and do they enjoy it does a woman leave
you for the fish man
that's what you know would my girlfriend
leave me for the fish man
like that i got that from they got that
yeah well this would be that would be
the teenage fear
that what happens if [ __ ] she thinks
that that fish man is hotter than me
okay yeah scales and [ __ ] oh yeah i
could see that
he could breathe underneath the water
yeah kind of a merman thing
well now you're making me oh
isn't that what creature from the black
lagoon was all about those essentially
yeah
of her swimming and the creature [ __ ]
looking at her and [ __ ]
that looked like a damn love scene to me
yeah yeah that's some trans species love
right there
yeah gilman gilman was pretty cute
yeah nothing was ugly no he wasn't okay
he was at least he was physically he was
just misunderstood
misunderstood he was just misunderstood
yeah i mean and they tried to make him
live on land didn't they by sewing his
gills shut or something
didn't they try to do something today
did they do that in the first one
weirdly i remember the second one
revenge of the creature more than the
first one because revenge of the
creature was on mystery science theater
so i've seen it a lot more times than
the first one
but he was still in the water and he was
like back in the [ __ ] amazon or
whatever in the second one so i don't
remember what happened at the end of the
first one
did he just like go back and i wanted to
be like just keep your lady god damn
yeah [ __ ] everyone's so judgmental
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god well he's so slippery i love
that yeah
oh my god we're well we're already in
that mindset because we recorded a
we recorded a movie retrospective
earlier about a very
um perverse
film yeah if you're on patreon you know
what movie we're talking about but
you know so that's probably why that's
gonna be the next show one next one
coming up yeah
thursday for patreon so there's anything
else you want to say about this movie i
don't think so like i said
um you know it's on shutter at least in
the us i don't know about uk
um you know it's it's a really good i i
really liked it i liked i thought the
acting was good it was like
you know fun had some funny [ __ ] just
don't expect it to be like scary or like
a horror movie
because it's kind of not it's sort of
like an indie 90s
relationship movie yeah with a monster
in it yeah
and and t tila go out go check out
blowfly they even got a damn documentary
up
up on about him on on youtube for free
but check out some of that [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] funny fourth drawer down says if
tom goes spawning around my place he's
gonna get shot in the ass
it's a fish's world gonna come and spawn
with your girl
that rhymed at everything yeah yeah
sorry i just had a really funny mental
picture of tom because spawning
yeah yeah like
[Laughter]
i saw he'll be like in your pool i saw
the humanoids from the deep trailer
when i was in the backseat of the car
had to drive in my parents up front it
must have been about 75 or 76 yeah when
did that come out
yeah it was in mid-70s i wanted to i saw
i saw that trailer and i was going
whoa it [ __ ] wigged me out i didn't
see it until much later
later it looked good yeah it looked good
i thought it was cool
they did it on didn't they do it on the
new mst
like with jonah in them i'm pretty sure
they did it on there
i don't know i don't remember yeah i'd
have to look on netflix now i kind of
want to watch that again
if they did yeah i'm almost i'm 95
percent sure
that yeah that the new mst did it yeah
it's he blowfly
he's an artist he's a florida artist
singer and rapper multimedia star
he died a while ago we mixed we missed
his his last tour
he was well it was about that was the
last year i think
yeah i think it was because that was
only a few years he's a superhero and a
singer and a rapper
kind of like dolomite but but better
better
and dirtier super
but funny yeah
i recommend a song called uh begging for
[ __ ] medley go [ __ ] watch that one
this is all the songs about begging for
[ __ ] i've kind of put them all together
one big super cut the meaning of the
song the meaning of the song
is he's saying you don't understand
these other celebrities are begging for
[ __ ] and he sings all these favorite
famous songs from these other artists
and that you didn't realize that they
were
you just got to see it you got to listen
to it it's [ __ ] funny
mango says stop spawning in my pond tom
ross yeah
tom's gonna be spawning uh but yeah it
looks kind of sketchy
oh it is it is oh it's sketchy as [ __ ]
it's sketchy as [ __ ] you dealing with
the ultimate florida man
the ultimate florida man if it's it's
it's supposed to be sketchy
and he's very famous you know i mean a
lot of he influenced a lot of
rap artists you know snoop dogg
and [ __ ] nwa and just everybody you
know they knew that
that is and he never really sold that
many albums you had to go to the show a
lot most of the time you just sell them
to you
um directly is where usually where you
got it and uh
and they were little bitty uh labels
from what i remember they're just like
[ __ ] filthy absolutely
[Laughter]
but it was a strange genius to them he
did covers he
one of his albums is called 2001 a sex
odyssey
and every song on it is some kind of 80s
cover or sometimes late 70s cover of a
great rock song or a great
you know dark wave song like prince
covers
uh [ __ ] another one was a blue monday
cover
f and [ __ ] just hilarious
and he's going to give you his own
perverted take on that damn song
hilarious seth says she's got a wiener
would be my favorite yeah she's got a
wiener that's a good one
yes she's got a wiener go ahead and
listen to that one
um t he goes down to the park
i'm not going to tell the story he tells
him to tell a story
how his heart was captivated by this
chick that had a wiener
and uh couldn't get her couldn't get her
out of his mind it's it's it's a
romantic tragedy
it's a romantic tragedy
it sounds pretty tragic oh it's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah she got a wiener
your stalker says is the movie spring
breakers an accurate depiction of
florida
um sort of i don't know like i grew up
in daytona beach
and uh when we had spring break there
like yeah the [ __ ] you saw in the movies
that was pretty accurate i wasn't going
down there hanging out with them because
they were a bunch of [ __ ] hooligans
falling off the [ __ ] balconies and
whatnot that's how shitty we were it's
like these stupid drunken college
students they'd be like getting drunk
i'm gonna climb up to the top floor you
can't stop me and then they drive and
then they fall and splatter all over the
pool thing and we're just like yeah good
riddance
yeah jackasses there's a difference
between people that live in florida and
tourists
and also people that move to florida
it's kind of like california crazy
[ __ ] moving to california but
now they're moving to florida
a lot of a lot of a lot of uh new york
and a lot of california's moving to
florida now they're talking about
sealing the borders off because they
that's [ __ ] fun because it'll
overpopulate quick if those
two states move here well yeah i mean we
still got a lot of room but yeah
it is kind of like developing let's
develop an awful [ __ ] grandfather
says stalker i'm just a supportive
viewer i just
i tease i tease yeah i'm an [ __ ] you
know
you'll figure that out evidently i went
to high school with you or you just
remember every [ __ ] thing i say
although you you seem to have known some
stuff that only somebody who
went to high school with me would know
see there you go yeah so
yeah yeah we still haven't solved the
mission oh yeah i'm not worried about it
[Laughter]
there's a lot of them i went to high
school with i was just wondering
if he doesn't want to tell me who it is
it's probably a girl
yeah it's probably a girl yeah okay yeah
i'm just saying one of these days we'll
figure it out yeah
all right so you you ready to wrap it up
yeah all right yeah i gotta go
[ __ ] man i woke up at four o'clock in
the goddamn morning why do i keep doing
that i don't know
i congress if you if you were a girl
disguised as a guy you wouldn't you
wouldn't claim to be a girl you'd claim
to be a guy so i don't believe what you
say
it's a conspiracy conspiracy
all right all right so um yeah we'll be
back tomorrow talk about another movie i
got one i gotta
i'm planning to watch tonight unless i
just stumble across something else
so uh yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye